[Music]
this intergenerational piece the
patterns that I that recur in my life
are the result of of you know how it was
brought up or you know things that
happen to me Etc there's a attention or
a disconnect between that sovereignty
that we're seeking to embody and the
autopilot nature with which you know we
live our lives for the most part
unconscious of we're all here to do
better than our parents to live a little
bit more enlightened than those who came
before us and to really see unhealthy
patterns and then shoulder the
responsibility to somehow arrest them so
that you're not only perpetrating them
yourself but also as a parent passing
them on to the next generation
is there any more worthy work to do
right like that is a it's been like
extraordinary for me